Speaker 1: Let's talk briefly about former
Democrat and former Democratic presidential
candidate and former Democratic Congresswoman
Tulsi Gabbard. The other day on Twitter, I asked
the question, what is Tulsa's next pivot now that
almost everyone or is it everyone she endorsed,
lost or may lose? We found out what the next pivot
is going to be, and I'm going to tell you in a
moment. But before we do that, if you want to find
someone with an even worse endorsement record than
Trump, you have to look at Tulsi. Look at this,
The New Republic with a nice write up about this.
Nearly every Republican, Tulsi Gabbard, endorsed
lost the election. These are the numbers. Tulsi
Gabbard endorsed 13 Republican candidates and
ten of them lost and she endorsed some real
extremists. For someone who has made the claim
that it is the Democratic Party that lost her,
that she is leaving the Democratic Party
because she is the moderate. She is the critical
thinker. She is the, for lack of a better term,
enlightened, centrist. And then all of a sudden,
she's endorsing Herschel Walker. She's
endorsing Kerry Lake, John Gibbs. That's
not critical thinking and it's certainly not
moderation. Those are some of the most extreme
candidates out there. The New Republic summarized
this. She in the House endorsed John Gibbs,
who I interviewed. He's out of his mind. And he
lost Tom Barrett and Joe Kent. All of them lost
on the Senate side. She endorsed Blake Masters,
who thankfully lost one of the worst and most
dangerous candidates this cycle, Adam Laxalt in
Nevada. Thankfully, he lost. And Don Bolduc in
New Hampshire, good thing he lost as well. And
then as far as governors go. Tulsi endorsed Cory
Lake. We learned yesterday that, yes, indeed,
she lost. Darren Bailey in Illinois lost. Tudor
Dixon in Michigan, she lost. And Lee Zeldin in
New York. The three people she endorsed who won
were J.D. Vance for Ohio senator. He was already
well ahead at the point at which she endorsed him.
Mike Lee for Utah senator. Okay. That's maybe the
most contested one here, even though he was doing
very well in the polls. And then Kristi Noem
for South Dakota governor. She's very popular
in South Dakota. Meaningless endorsement. She
was obviously going to win. So a disastrous
endorsement record for Tulsi. So then we get to
what is her next step? What's her next pivot?
Some of you wrote to me and said to us his next
pivot is going to be becoming overtly transphobic
because that's what's doing really well right
now among the Republican Party. Well, maybe. But
the actual news is that Tulsi Gabbard has joined
Fox News. We used to joke about this months and
months and months ago when a year, maybe longer,
when we started to see the TULSI transformation.
We all were joking. She is really lined up to
be a Fox News contributor and it was a joke.
But one of those jokes where you say, well, it
actually could become a reality. She is now a
fox news contributor. The hill reporting. Tulsi
gabbard, inks contributor deal with fox news.
A spokesperson for fox confirmed gabbard's hiring
on tuesday. She has emerged as a leading critic
of liberals and has been campaigning with a
number of Trump backed Republicans during the
recent cycle. She regularly has appeared on Fox
over several months. She has guest hosted Tucker
Carlson tonight. She was on Fox's afternoon table
talk program, the five, and occupied the seat
typically reserved for Democrats and liberals. So
is this the end of. I mean, listen, we're dealing
with a right winger now. Tulsi Gabbard is the
absolutely typical reactionary populist ask. I
don't even know if the word libertarian applies.
She was very clearly a Democrat because being a
Democrat was how she was going to be elected to
the House representing her home state of Hawaii.
And there was really nothing special about being
a Democrat. Some of the people who fawned over her
from the left were saying, well, she's against
regime change wars. Who is? Who is? And, oh,
Hillary was going to get us into three wars, was
she? Biden's going to get us into three wars.
Well, he hasn't so far. And he's halfway through
his first term. Once that fell out of favor or is
no longer useful. She started the pivot. Well,
we need to defend speech and there's a little
too much wokeness and suppression of speech on
the left. And I can see it clearly because I'm
inside. It was all B.S. and she has now gone
full circle. She endorsed the most extremist
lunatics running in 2022. Just about every single
one of them lost, thankfully. And now she's a Fox
News contributor. What does she have to look
forward to? Well, maybe this check this out.